in the transcriptomics one course we
cover key concepts needed to understand
the analysis of NGS gene expression data
we've already discussed how genes are
expressed in the cell and how we can run
a bioinformatics analysis pipeline to
process RNA seek data which generates a
table of expression in this video we
will discuss further downstream analysis
steps of working with our table after
the RNA seek analysis pipeline finished
we got several files in the download
folder which were organized by type of
expression being axon Aiza form and gene
and normalization which was TPM fpkm or
raw count we can open these tables of
expression naming table manipulation
software such as Microsoft Excel
OpenOffice or even our when we started
the analysis we had a library of
unstructured data unorganized reads in a
text file also called fast queue or fast
a the output from the pipeline is called
structured data where columns are sample
names and rows our gene or isoform IDs
in in Samba format inside each cell we
will find the quantified expression
levels depending on the input and
quantification approach we selected this
number is reported in fpkm rpkm
TPM or raw count units looking through
the table you will notice that some
genes start with the letters EMS G or en
St and some start with EMS mus G or en
as mu s T these ID names show whether
these are mouse or human genes and
isoforms in some cases you will also
find road names starting with Excel OC a
special name given by cufflinks two
unidentified isoforms the Y access on
this bar chart shows the level of
expression where the bars represent an
expression profile of a given gene or
isoform this table contains thousands of
genes and isoforms so we need to
summarize this data to explore the
expression profiles of interest
one of the main challenges in downstream
analysis is to find a specific gene or
gene sets' and annotate them by their
biological functions to understand what
expression differences can be observed
and collected samples before we start
looking for specific genes we need to
summarize the full dataset to do so we
often use a box plot that shows how all
the values are distributed between
samples if we have multiple datasets
which in our case is the sample data of
gene expression with multiple samples
box plots help compare the samples using
statistical properties these are the
mean median and the bulk of the data
which is the interquartile range versus
the outliers when we prepare a box plot
of a typical RNA seek data set we can
see that the gene expression levels are
heavily skewed in linear scale in this
plot you can see that the majority of
the data points that are supposed to be
in the interquartile range are barely
visible however the outliers which
represent the top 25% of the data in the
box plot are sketched out and are
clearly visible this type of
distribution will interfere with many of
the statistical tests we plan to use to
analyze our gene expression data if we
transform our values into log scale we
will see a much more normal bar plot now
it is easier to compare values between
samples without losing the detail of
lower expressed values and still see the
highest and lowest values clearly let's
see how this transformation effects
distribution of levels in one of the
samples we are looking at here for this
sample you can see a more normal
distribution after we apply the
logarithmic scale to all the values this
procedure of normalization is often
called log normal transformation and it
makes the data more symmetrical as a
result a parametric statistical test
will provide us with more power which is
a more accurate and relevant answer
another useful transformation you might
want to consider for NGS or microarray
data is quantile normalization this is
most useful when you have a number of
conditions you want to compare
assuming the samples in each group are
biological replicates quanto
normalization arranges expression values
in similar order between samples and
aligns their means you might want to do
this for only a portion of the data for
example leaving the top express genes
untouched as a result the data will be
very close to normal distribution then
the means of each sample will be
normalized as a result some genes that
do not have very strong differences in
expression will be less significantly
different but the overall differences
between samples will not change this is
important for noisy data where thousands
of observations about each condition can
be influenced by various technical
variables to test this assumption we can
compare a couple of samples in the same
group under the same condition as TN
breast cancer and plot all the gene
expression data in a scatter plot if the
samples were identical their levels of
expression would be aligned perfectly
along the diagonal red line if they are
correlated the values would be stretched
out along this line you can see here
that the transformed data is better
correlated between samples now that we
prepared the raw expression data let's
see what we can learn about our data set
as a whole to study how gene expression
can be used to measure variability
between samples we can use a
dimensionality reduction technique that
is often used for RNA seek data
principal component analysis or PCA this
analysis method will help us to
visualize the multi-dimensional data set
in a scatter plot and see what gene
expression patterns show about the data
but first let's talk about
dimensionality what does it mean if you
look at our table of expression
we'll see that it has thousands of rows
and several columns for samples if we
take the first two genes and eight
samples we can visualize the samples in
a two dimensional space by taking the
expression values of two genes across
eight samples genes are dimensions seen
here as the X and y axis and samples are
objects which are dots in this
two-dimensional space
to incorporate additional information
offered by other genes we can add
another gene to the space and get a
three-dimensional view of our samples
but we have thousands of genes in our
table of expression how can we visualize
variants between samples using all of
this data how can we view the samples in
a multi-dimensional space which is R
raised to the N power the answer is that
you can't because we are limited by
visualization in three dimensions but
what we can do is reduce the
multi-dimensional space into two or
three dimensions that best represents
our data this is called dimensionality
reduction when we reduce the number of
dimensions to gain insights about the
data set as a whole if we use the
approach of principal components we are
looking for such a plane which are
vectors in the multi-dimensional space
we cannot see that explained variance in
our data in the best possible way here
is data with low variance the samples
are close together and here is a sample
set with higher variance
however this variance is not well
explained by the x and y axes but you
could draw a line through the original
space that shows the maximum variance of
this data set this vector through the
multi-dimensional space that maximizes
the variance of the data is called
principal component just like with our
previous example we can add other
principal components such as PC 2 or
even PC 3 thus visualizing our data by
projecting it onto a space of two or
three axes that explain some percentage
of data variance when we select the
principal components that explain the
most variance of our data we can project
all of our samples into this space and
visualize the full data set this
technique is called principal component
analysis and it can be very helpful in
the initial stages of our analysis let's
take a look again at our table of
expression the genes or rows are
dimensions and the columns are sample
names which are objects now let us run a
pipeline that will include the steps
we've discussed so far log normal
transformation quantile normalization
and principle component analysis to
visualize our data as well as see how
different samples are based on their
gene expression on the T bio info
platform select an unsupervised analysis
section under data mining once you are
inside upload the gene expression table
and tab delimited txt file pipeline we
can build here will include quant L
normalization we will transform data to
log normal scale and select the
threshold of five as well as PCA where
we can also filter the data using
various thresholds as a result of the
principal component analysis we'll get a
table of values for each principal
component associated with each object or
sample in our dataset columns will also
contain a percentage of variance that
each component explains we can visualize
our data by assigning coordinates for
each sample based on the principal
components that best explain the
variance of our data notice that we can
see a distinction between the samples
and the triple negative and estrogen
receptor-positive samples by their
positions on the x-axis we can also
notice an outlier sample in the TN group
based on the y coordinate we can liken
PCA to a photographer trying to find the
best angle for a picture that will
capture as much detail as possible while
showing us the most information about
the group as a whole we would typically
use this method to visualize and explore
our data when using this multivariate
analysis method it is important to play
around with the data using normalization
and filtering while paying attention to
outliers for the best possible
interpretation in this video we reviewed
several approaches important for working
with our table of expression log normal
transformation quantile normalization
and principal component analysis at the
end of this course you will have a
chance to review all the contents
covered as well as practice what you've
learned on sample projects